[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm going to be joined here at the
interval in san francisco by our speaker
today
prana singh who comes to us through a
partnership that we have had for several
years
with kasbas the center for advanced
studies and behavioral sciences at
stanford
praerna has been studying virology
pandemics
nationalism and most importantly at this
point vaccine acceptance and how all
these things come together
and tonight she's going to give us a
history of that as well as how it might
apply
to our present situation here in our own
pandemic
welcome purna singh thank you xander
it's an honor to be here at the long now
foundation and in my research i
look to the past to understand how to
promote human flourishing
today and in the future and in that i
see my aims as very much
in alignment with the goals of the
foundation
so infectious diseases have posed one of
the most serious
and long-standing challenges to
humankind especially since settled
agriculture and the domestication of
animals
infectious diseases have not only been
the single
largest cause of human morbidity and
mortality
they've also generated enormous social
tumult triggering the economic reversals
of fortunes in the collapse of once
mighty political empires and decisively
shaped the trajectory
of world history in the past couple of
centuries but especially in the 20th
century we have made
unprecedented medical advances in
research and treatments
and yet covet 19 is a stark reminder
of the grave threat that we continue to
face from a host of deadly diseases
naturally occurring but also the use of
germs
as a tool of bioterrorism
for me as a social scientist the control
of infectious disease represents a
fertile
and yet relatively under explored site
of interactions between the state and
its people
so historically the control of disease
has been an important driving force for
the development of states
as we think of them today so charles
tilley famously
argued that wars make states
and yet historians have shown that in as
much as military conflict
it was war against an often more deadly
foe than an enemy army disease
that prompted the extension of the state
into previously
autonomous social domains on the one
hand
contagion prompted the development of
institutions of control
civilian law enforcement agencies police
customs migration
intelligence services quarantines
and pandemics led to the establishment
and strengthening of health
bureaucracies
city health boards that marked the
exertion
of unprecedented state power over
societal actors like the church
city boards regularly overruled the
clergy
in prohibiting festivals processions and
gatherings
on the other hand contagion also
encouraged the development of
institutions of
care such as poor laws relief for the
needy
that underlay the emergence of welfare
states
the control of disease and healthcare in
general thus gradually went from being a
private realm
dominated by religious and kinship based
organizations
to being recognized as within the
jurisdiction of
and then also a key responsibility
of a state towards its people so
roosevelt famously said that the success
of failure of any government in the
final analysis
must be measured by the health of its
citizens
and key to this is the protection
against disease
but if we think of conceptualizing how
capable states
are in terms of how effectively they
control
infectious disease it's important to
recognize that this
is a particular type of state capacity
that rests critically on a state's
ability to gain compliance with society
so let's think for a second of the
typology of the kinds of activities that
states
regularly undertake on the left you have
tasks that states can achieve without
much active participation from society
economic planning
the dispensation of justice building of
public infrastructure
on the right on the other hand are
activities that states cannot be
successful
at without the compliance of society so
the best organized elections are only
successful if people vote
volunteer armies can only be raised if
people join them
a state's tax base often its main source
of revenue
rests on people willingly fairly paying
taxes
a state's public health policy is only
as successful
as the extent to which people comply
with it
historically states have elicited
compliance with their policies on this
rough spectrum
from coercive to voluntary on the
coercive end
forcible inspection reading of homes
separations of patients from families
segregation of contacts
compulsory sterilization compulsory
vaccination laws that may or may not be
accompanied by
force but such coercion is far from
ideal
it's costly to implement you need to
have information
you need to monitor and punish those who
are evading
and further coercion risks societal
pushback
through much of history people have gone
to great lengths to resist public health
mandates
in india colonial reports document how
families hid
plague victims in lofts in cupboards
in gardens in addition to such evasion
across much of the world coercive public
health policies have provoked
protests uprisings violent riots
even assaults on and the assassinations
of state employees
moving across the spectrum away from
coercion many states stop
short of making vaccines compulsory but
they may require them for access to
state resources schooling
employment and at the very end of this
scale we can think of compliance with
public health interventions
that is voluntary willingly extended
this is the most desired type of
compliance
but it is also the most elusive it
represents a category
within state tasks that require popular
participation
that following a group of fellow new
england economists i call
wicked hard so for one public health
is preventive unlike when we take a
pharmaceutical drug like a painkiller we
are not sick or suffering
when we undertake a public health
intervention we are taking that action
preemptively to protect us in the future
and we know from many studies that
humans tend to be presentist
we discount the future public health
advice
can because of its link to science be
dynamic and also possibly contradictory
this can be hard to process and further
public health interventions require
behavioral change
behavioral change that is intense and it
is intimate
therefore michelle foucault's term
biopower
public health directives entail
incursions testing
incisions into our bodies and those
of our often very young children changes
to our everyday established habits and
routines don't smoke
exercise wear a condom public health
directives can
as the pandemic has reminded us upend
how we live they can change how we die
alone or with our families they can
modify the rituals through which our
loved ones
remember us and send us onwards
in doing so they can rub against often
long-held norms beliefs and practices
they can challenge ways of
seeing and being in the world and they
can lead us to question who we are
what we know and our place in this
universe
compliance with many public health
directives such as vaccination
like some of those other tasks in the
second column voting
taxation conscription they represent
what we call collective action problems
so although society is better off if all
comply with their tax duties
each individual has an incentive to free
ride on the contribution of others
similarly for vaccination collective
action is necessary to attain
herd immunity but once it is reached
the benefits of decreased mortality and
morbidity are available to all
so given that like almost all health
interventions vaccines
entail some risks a poke some side
effects
individuals have an incentive to enjoy
the benefits of that common good
to take advantage of this positive
externality of herd immunity
conferred on them by others decisions to
vaccinate
without themselves bearing any of those
costs
so how then do you encourage compliance
with such a wicked hard task
in this next part of the talk i'll try
to answer this question by taking you on
a journey of how the world's
first ever vaccine was received in two
of the largest nations and oldest
civilizations in the world
china and india vaccines have been
hailed as the single most
important intervention in public health
immunization against
infectious diseases has protected more
children and adults from untimely deaths
than any other form of treatment the
world's
first vaccine was against smallpox one
of the oldest
and deadliest diseases to afflict
mankind it claimed about one in three
lives that often lets
left survivors blinded and almost
certainly disfigured
faces rendered this pitted pockmarked
lunar landscape
it was also a highly virulent contagious
disease
and this importance of smallpox is one
of history's greatest killers
is rivaled by its significance as the
subject
of quote the world's most triumphant
achievement
in medicine and public health the global
dissemination of the vaccine
led to the eradication of smallpox
through a global worldwide campaign led
by the who
it is to date the only human disease
to be eradicated from the globe both
china and india have very long histories
of smallpox they compete for the
orientalizing moniker of the cradle of
smallpox
both had highly well developed and
surprisingly resonant systems of beliefs
and practices around the disease
in line with the disease deities that
existed across much of the world
china and india had smallpox goddesses
in china and sitalamata in india and the
two goddesses
are strikingly similar as you can see in
their visual representations
in both china and india there were
traditional medical systems that saw
smallpox as a disease
of heat and patients followed a cooling
diet
beginning around the 16th century both
china and india witnessed the emergence
and spread of a new technique
which was embedded within and
accompanied by these rituals
the prophylactic practice of variolation
variola is the smallpox virus in order
to understand how variolation
worked let's think for a moment of how a
vaccine works
the fundamental idea behind a vaccine is
that if we are deliberately exposed to a
relatively harmless
or the dead version of a germ our immune
system will then recognize
and eliminate that germ rapidly if it
encounters it out in the world
this logic comes from the practice of
variolation which was an essential
precursor to vaccination
say you were a child in china or india
at this time
who was lucky enough to survive a case
of smallpox
a various usually an itinerant folk
healer and not
a classically trained physician who
charged quite a sum for their services
would collect some material from your
smallpox store
remember this is a key way in which
smallpox spread
and then use these scabs to produce a
mild but protective
infection in other children the
technique differed it was administered
through
nasal encephalation in china and
cutaneous incision into your arm in
india so if i was a child being violated
in canton
i would snort your scabs up my nose and
in calcutta the very later would scratch
it into my skin
very much like a modern day vaccine both
techniques were equally effective
so this technique of variolation was
carried from china and india into the
ottoman empire
and introduced through the advocacy of a
heroic lady
lady mary montague into britain
valuation then spread across much of
europe
also to north america and this
innovation from asia led to substantial
decreases in mortality across
other parts of the world this is edward
jenner
and he is credited with inventing
vaccines
when he was eight jenna was inoculated
like thousands of other children
in england later as a doctor in rural
england
interacting closely with dairy maids who
had a reputation for being especially
beautiful
the reason they did not have a quote
ugly
pockmarked face they reported to jenner
was because they were protected from
smallpox because they had gotten cowpox
now exposure to cowpox was a pretty
nasty disease if you were a cow
but it was quite benign if you were a
human and it protected you against
smallpox
jenner took this fork wisdom and
replaced the various
matter the smallpox scabs that were used
in variolation
with matter from the pustules of the cow
voila variola vaccinate latin
for smallpox of the cow the world's
first
ever vaccine in 1796 which coined the
term
vaccine itself now this vaccine
cloaked in the colonists language of
spreading civilization
is sent back to china and india homes of
the indigenous knowledge upon which it
was built
but from here on from the time that the
vaccine arrives in china and india at
the beginning of the 19th century
to the eradication of smallpox in the
mid 20th century it is two
very distinct stories in general a far
greater willing compliance with the
vaccine in china
than india i use my comparative
historical analysis
of the cities of canton and calcutta in
china and india
during the 19th century and of the
countries themselves
in the mid 20th century to develop what
i call
a moral theory of compliance what do i
mean by this
a moral theory of vaccination has two
components
the messenger who is asking for
compliance
and the message how is compliance
elicited how is it framed
what is it that compliance is being
sought for
this moral theory is rooted in a
fundamentally different understanding of
us and how we think and behave than the
much criticized and yet dominant
rational actor model
homo economicus is a rational interest
maximizer
in order to get homo economics to comply
with the public health intervention
you just need to give her some more
information about it costs and benefits
homo economics will tally this up
and if the advantages outweigh the risks
would she roll up her sleeve
and yet we know that facts don't change
our minds studies have shown that
providing people more
information about vaccines is not only
often
ineffective it can actually backfire
in contrast research and social
psychology but also increasingly in
neuroscience
shows that we develop attitudes and take
actions
in much more complex ways unlike homo
economicus who processes information in
a neutral bayesian manner
and maximizes interests homomoralis
thinks and acts in biased motivated ways
so to return to my moral theory of
compliance who is asking people to
vaccinate
must have a relationship of authority of
trust
of legitimacy with the people and the
message matters
my research brought out how public
health messaging is more likely to
resonate if it fits with two sources of
motivation
cognitive and affective and i'll discuss
each in turn
let's begin with the cognitive we strive
as humans for cognitive consonants we
are more likely to accept new
information as the sociologist
leon festinger said if we can find a
schema
through which to link the stimulus to
previously understood experiences
immortaversky and daniel kahneman
famously
had the familiarity heuristic that a
statement compatible with established
beliefs or understandings it feels more
familiar
it leads to a sense of cognitive ease
and the statement is therefore more
believable
information that is not cognitively
compatible that
constitutes a rejection of what we know
is more likely to in turn be rejected
at least initially so in the city of
canton in imperial china in the early
19th century
vaccination was willingly adopted and a
key
reason for this was that it was promoted
by the local gentry
the gentry are either state officials or
they are closely linked to the state
through there having been conferred a
degree in the imperial exam system
but they also have strong ties to
society a system of confucian norms and
the mandate of heaven
prompts the local gentry over many
centuries to be responsible and
accountable
for the welfare of people so they enjoy
a long legacy of trust and authority
and the way that the gentry endorses
this new generation vaccine
was by embedding it within traditional
established
ways of thinking about and treating
smallpox
one of the ways that the gentry promoted
vaccination was by writing
prefaces for a vaccination manual
written by one of the first vaccinators
in southern china
chushi who had learnt the technique from
the surgeon general of the east india
company alexander pearson
churchis manual was technically a
translation of a manual written by
pearson
but the translation did a few things to
creatively
link the vaccine to the principles and
practices of chinese medicine
for one church he got rid of this whole
method of inoculation discovered in the
kingdom of england so he changes the
title
he adopts the writing style and the
illustrations of traditional chinese
medicine texts
a further sinusization is that he adopts
the same
pre and postoperative dietary and ritual
protocols that had accompanied
violation and finally remember that
varioulation had happened in canton
through nasal encephalation you're
snorting the scabs up your nose
and now in the vaccine there is an
incision into the arm
by a vaccination landsat that is
radically new
now she and the gentry who are endorsing
his manual
make this acceptable by linking it to
the familiar
needling technique of acupuncture
vaccination manuals such as this
use ornate illustrations in traditional
drawing
styles to show vaccinators how to make
incisions
along acupuncture meridians that
corresponded with smallpox
the customary cooling diet was also
maintained and often the general vaccine
was
accompanied by traditional herbal
formulas
in contrast the vaccine meets with a far
cooler reception in 19th century
calcutta
it arrives at exactly the same time in
both canton and calcutta it's introduced
by the same agent the east india company
and these cities are key entrepreneurs
in the european especially the british
trading system
in fact trade between calcutta and
canton silver
tea and eventually opium is the
lifeblood of british imperialism
and you can get a sense of the
importance of the two cities from this
painting of the three
money brothers all employed by the
british east india company
that was commissioned by their father mr
money where the fingers of robert and
james money are pointing to
canton and calcutta respectively so
calcutta shares many socioeconomic
political similarities with canton
but unlike in canton the vaccine in
calcutta is resisted
an important reason is that british
colonial officials
do not have the same degree of trust or
legitimacy
as the gentry further because the
colonists spread a vaccination was part
of a civilizing mission
this led them to present the vaccine as
something totally new and different from
the established practice of valuation
especially the worship of sitala in
which variation was embedded
so variolation which as i mentioned was
very effective and in fact
formed the basis of knowledge on which
jenner built
was now described by the east india
company in calcutta
as backward and is dangerous
and yet even though the technology of
the vaccine was very
similar to variolation much more similar
than in canton because people were
accustomed to having an incision into
their skin
yet most residents of calcutta and the
surrounding areas of bengal
avoided vaccination and continue to
prefer various
in colonial documents you repeatedly see
reference to how a big reason for this
was
what medical historian david arnold has
termed the quote
raw secularity of vaccination this is a
quote from one of the vaccine reports
that says
that the principal objection to
vaccination
was that it was done without any puja or
worship
or sacrificial offering unfortunately
the bulk of my archival sources for this
period are colonial documents
and these are unsurprisingly laced with
the racist judgments of their writers
colonial
officers in the service of the east
india company like the money brothers
and the resistance of indians to the
vaccine is attributed to their
superstition
their prejudice but in fact the way in
which
vaccines were framed constituted a
cognitive
and cultural rupture with a cohesive
elaborate and in many ways
quite sophisticated system of
understanding and treating smallpox
it's interesting to note here that many
of the instances in calcutta in which
the vaccines were
accepted was when they were accompanied
by
all the same rituals that had
accompanied violation
so middle class households who could
afford it chose an auspicious day
for the operation they observed the old
rituals the dietary taboos they employed
a priest
and as arnold writes somewhat
tongue-in-cheek
they thanked sithala rather than jenner
sahib
for the child's safe passage
fast forward more than a sanctuary india
in the 1970s at the peak of the world
health organization's global smallpox
eradication
campaign smallpox has been eradicated in
africa south asia is one of the last
outposts of the virus and the who has
shifted from a strategy of
universal vaccination to what is known
as surveillance
containment a zealous and committed
cardras of
indian doctors and health workers and
foreign epidemiologists are going from
village to village
to locate cases of smallpox and
vaccinate
all contacts in a ring to stop
transmission
of the virus now if you read the report
of this campaign a somewhat dry document
called the management of smallpox in
india
it's dedicated to a spiritual leader
neem karoli baba by all accounts an
extraordinary mystic who was also the
guru of ramdas timothy leary krishna das
but how it was that this report penned
by a doctor from san francisco dr larry
brilliant
came to be dedicated to neem karoli baba
i'll let you figure that out
and the hint is that you might want to
dig into the archives of the long now
foundation seminars
but if you read this report and other
reports you can see the
importance of smallpox zero teams as
they were called
convincing local notables religious
leaders to endorse the vaccination
and how important this was for them to
convince people
to roll up their sleeve further even
though there was a substantial
foreign and western presence and role in
the campaign
under the advice of culturally sensitive
epidemiologists like dr brilliant
they were very aware of the cultural
morals and rituals associated with
sithala
indeed the smallpox zero teams realized
that the families of smallpox patients
might evade them but they would never
hide from the goddess
so they camped at sitla mandir's to
detect cases
and convince family members to be
vaccinated
and they often set up vaccination
stations at sitala temples
in doing so they actively presented
themselves
as working with indeed even devotees of
the goddess sithala
rather than working against her by this
time smallpox had been effectively
eradicated from china for about two
decades
communist china mao had taken power in
1949 was able to eradicate smallpox
through a mass vaccination campaign in
the early 1950s
so in line with that first messenger
component
of my moral theory of compliance a large
part of the success was because the
vaccination campaign was launched by the
chinese communist party
who enjoyed a tremendous degree of
legitimacy having emerged out of
decades of long bitter fighting first
with the gomandang
and then the japanese vaccination had
the full support of mao who was hugely
popular in the 1950s
this is still well before the disasters
of the great leap forward and the
cultural revolution
and at the grassroots level it was
communicated by the communist party
cadres who were deeply embedded in
and enjoyed the trust of local
communities
vaccination was part of the patriotic
health campaigns
you were getting vaccinated to protect
the health of your nation
and this gets to this second affective
source of motivation
in my moral theory of compliance so i
tried to present evidence for compliance
because of cognitive motivations that
public health directives were more
likely to be accepted
if they were linked to our established
beliefs norms and practices about
sickness and health
but willingness to vaccinate and
compliance with health interventions
more broadly
is also greater if it taps into our
affective
sources of solidarity what i have in my
previous writings called a sense
of weakness nationalism is a
particularly potent form of venus
in my first book i showed how feelings
of national solidarity lead to a
perception of a linked fate
a shared destiny which helps put in
place social policies for the common
good
indeed nationalism has been a powerful
driver of popular mobilizations
against colonialism across asia and
africa from the 40s to the 60s
against communism across eastern europe
and the former soviet union
in the 1990s and states have effectively
drawn
on this powerful motor of nationalism to
encourage compliance with those tasks
that present collective action dilemmas
remember getting citizens to pay their
taxes
joining your army and possibly laying
down your life for your country
so in conclusion compliance with public
health interventions remains one of the
most
pressing challenges of our time we can
see this today
in the challenges of attaining herd
immunity against covid
but before and beyond in 2019 the who
identified vaccine hesitancy
as one of the top 10 threats to global
health
effectively addressing this challenge
begins from a better understanding of
ourselves
a humbler understanding homo morales is
a messy
motivated emotional decision maker
but also a richer understanding we are
driven
not just by maximizing our narrowly
defined
interests but also by our perceptions of
trustworthiness
legitimacy by norms and values by shared
identities and solidarities
we are mere mortals but we are
also moral mortals and this
is our strength thank you
well that was really fantastic um i'm
here today next door to the interval uh
at the hang gallery because now the
interval our headquarters and bar and
cafe is now fully open
uh but i'd love to welcome uh purna
singh who's joining us
uh for the questions from her home in
providence rhode island welcome berna
thank you so much sanja it's a pleasure
to be here so great to have you
uh and i'm glad that you were able to do
your fellowship out at stanford during
the summer and we were able to record
your talk here then um but also glad to
have you
here live from your home um and um
in a little bit we're actually going to
be joined by uh by dr larry brilliant
who uh you featured in the talk and in
your in your work
um and um really great to have him as
about the previous speaker and as well
as
you know as you mentioned one of the
people who led the efforts to you know
eradicate one of the only truly
eradicated disease so
um i'm sure that would be great um i
wanted to get into a couple questions
that i have and we'll also bring some
questions in from there our live
audience
um one of the first ones i want to talk
a little bit about is this jenner story
i mean he's often you know he's he's
credited
as a as an inventor or a discoverer and
yet he really was
was act you know bringing folk knowledge
into um
a more common and modern practice and
how do you how do you like to talk about
invention versus discovery and how these
things
get brought into the i guess it would
call the modern world
i think it's a great question xander and
thank you for asking it i always find it
interesting um i forget exactly where i
read it
which was talking about how jenna is
described in history books in different
parts of the world
and of course in british and european
history books he's described as
the inventor of vaccines even though we
should keep in mind and of course this
links to the whole anti-vaccination
vaccine hesitancy question today that
i'm sure we'll get to
is that at the time of his invention
jenna was ostracized by the medical
community
within britain within england it itself
so there was a lot of suspicion a lot of
doubt a lot of hesitancy
around the nature of this intervention
that he had made
and it was a very pus it was a it was a
kind of leap of imagination
for many to be able to kind of take this
knowledge on board
even though as you point out it actually
built
on centuries of knowledge that existed
in india and china
so the point that i wanted to make is
that so in these so one his
invention meets with a lot of resistance
and is not automatically heralded
as an invention people call him a quack
even within
england on the other hand i find it
quite interesting that french
encyclopedias of the time
do not attribute to him the
status of an inventor they prefer to
call it the discovery of vaccines
and i think that to some extent of
course refers to the anglo-french
rivalry that has of course extended into
science
but i think is also in some ways um i
would i don't want to say more accurate
but at least an accurate bringing in of
the fact that at this point in time
some of the early impetuses to
colonialism were of course to collect
materia medica and to understand
the knowledge systems which in china and
india were far more sophisticated
in many ways than the kind of heroic
medicine or bloodletting
that was dominant in europe and so to
some extent i think you know invention
discovery but also the kind of impetus
of what was happening just the
geopolitics of colonialism of the time
and how quickly that shifted you know so
vaccines are so interesting historically
because they really represented in many
ways the first
thing that kind of the the europeans had
on the colonies or so they thought you
know so this was an
a clear to them kind of something better
than what existed of course what that
meant was that they had to completely
discard
and deliberately in a way undermine
the knowledge upon which the discovery
or the invention of the vaccine was
built
and so suddenly variolation was backward
it was suspicious i mean of course it
was dangerous the key thing about
variolation
was that you know it would be the
equivalent would be actually giving
someone a case of covet
a controlled case of covid but like
covet because these are transmissible
diseases the danger was that it was
transmissible
in the way that of course you know
you're not contagious when you get a
vaccine
and so of course there were dangers
associated with violation but
in one fell stroke with the kind of
colonial
discovery the british discovery the
western european
discovery it suddenly became that you
know the knowledge variation was
was painted as extremely dangerous very
backward
and so i think there are all these kind
of politics um in which kind of
vaccination represents a really
important moment
both for public health but also for the
understanding of geopolitics and your
question about
invention versus discovery i think gets
to the gets right to the heart of it
indeed i think you know there's such an
interesting nationalistic component to
this which you know we're now seeing
with
vaccine hesitancy having nationalist
elements now
with cobit but you know so many
technologies whether it's
you know astronomy or clock making even
were
invented centuries earlier in the east
slowly got to
develop or migrated um to um
to europe and then were reintroduced and
had so much hesitancy
coming back in um because they felt that
there were these
uh there were these imperialists and
colonialist uh thing
you know pieces of information or pieces
of technology even though many of
almost all of them i mean as kevin kelly
likes to point out every single
technology was invented in the east
aside from the scientific method
um which somehow got missed um but um
i think it's it's there's this seems to
be a history of this throughout
time um and so it's when we're you know
now once again living through another
version of
where nationalism and um and science
kind of do not agree with each other so
i really appreciate this as part of that
as part of your work
and i mean it kind of gets us to this
thing that you pointed out which is this
very sobering reality
uh that facts don't change minds um and
you know we often see
people trying to use facts to change
minds but i think you really pointed out
um you know both in in uh larry
brilliant's work and then this other
work that
you kind of have to meet people where
they're at you have to people both
physically and
and culturally and i'd love if you could
just talk a little bit
more about that and maybe how that might
apply better to
the situation we're in now yeah so i
you know this is this is not heartening
research
in many ways and i think it's research
that also doesn't fit
as i said in the talk our own kind of
understandings of how we think
humans should behave right and so i
think that it's
and that's why i think it's different
difficult for us to take on board
and i still read these studies even
though i know them with a degree of
surprise of just
how little giving people information and
much of this came
before covet with the mmr vaccine which
of course became
the source of much controversy after a
completely debunked landsat article
by andrew wakefield but kind of has led
to this residue
of hesitancy and of course again just
rewind it led to the outbreak of measles
of
for decades why is it that this
information
doesn't change our mind and it gets i
think
to this alternate understanding of
humans
as decision makers who are motivated by
moral
concerns and so i think you know i kind
of feel as if
i want to kind of shift the debate and
the attention
away from the hand ringing and the
pessimism and frustration
that often accompanies our reading of
these studies that show that giving
people more information about
costs and benefits and risks and how
safe vaccines are
doesn't lead to that change in behavior
that we anticipate
to kind of shift it to say that well
let's then really emphasize what does
change behavior and historically
we have a rich repertoire of evidence
about what does change behavior and i
would love to kind of you know
hear dr brilliant kind of coming in on
this at some point uh but you know the
fact that at that
in those very last stages of the
eradication of smallpox
it wasn't necessarily that they were
giving people more information about the
disease in fact if anything
smallpox was a disease that was all too
familiar to people
but i think you know the way that i put
it in the in my
in the talk and the way that i talk
about it in my book
is about both the kind of cognitive and
the affective so both you know where
as you said where are we at in terms of
almost everyone
has certain sets of norms and
understandings about what makes
us sick and what's going to make us
healthy and i think kind of
understanding what people think of as
making them sick and
and making them well is really important
we know that there's an association in
the us
between people who believe in alternate
forms of medicine
and a certain degree of vaccine
hesitancy we knew this prior to the
covet pandemic
so again trying to understand you know
what what is their worldview
what is their understanding and to meet
that not with aggression or with
skepticism
or with hostility but to kind of really
meet it from a point of
meet that point of view from from a
stance of empathy
and then to kind of you know bring that
on board
uh as well as as i said so that's the
message part of it and the second part
is of course who is doing this
convincing i think you know the
kind of the agent of persuasion has to
be
and we've seen this again with kobed
someone who enjoys
the trust a degree of legitimacy on the
part of the people
and that might be a state official it
might be your pediatrician because
most diseases covet is very different in
some ways because it's a
actually unusual disease that we are
vaccinating ourselves as
adults for most infectious diseases we
receive vaccines as children
and so i think you know in in some ways
the pediatrician or the doctor
so we have to kind of really work hard
both into developing our understanding
of
a sympathetic understanding of of
people's repertoire
their norms about what constitutes
sickness and healing
and then you know the understanding what
their
what their kind of ecosystem of trust
and authority and legitimacy is
and the final thing that i'll say before
i turn it back to you xander
is that i think of nationalism here as
both
as both the promise but also the pitfall
of it and i think we sometimes tend to
talk about the drawbacks of nationalism
which are all too evident in the kind of
tragic vaccine nationalism that
continues
you know in india where i'm from there's
still a huge degree of vaccine scarcity
and yet we have this vaccine abundance
in the u.s
and much of this is a product of the
kind of vaccine nationalism
through which vaccines are being
distributed against covet
but i do want to kind of point out to
that part of my research that shows how
nationalism can be this affective motor
so if facts don't change our mind what
does right so having
vaccines be linked to the way that we
think about health and healing will
change our mind
but also it being linked to this emotion
you know how what are we motivated by
emotionally and i think their
nationalism has been such a
powerful motivator of humans
historically since the beginning of the
nation state people have been willing to
lay down their lives
for the nation and so i think you know
again the experience of the patriotic
health campaigns but also the experience
of cuba
and many other countries points to how
nationalism can be mobilized
as this very powerful affective tool
even though it remains this kind of very
dangerous divisive force as well
so you know you're right information
doesn't change our mind
but i try to want i want to kind of try
to focus on what does
change our mind and how we can take
those lessons to our understanding of
the present and the future
thank you and uh this would be a great
time to bring in uh
larry brilliant um he's joining us from
his home uh actually not too far from us
welcome larry
hello xander thank you for inviting me
in prana that was
wonderful both your talk right now and
your book
and the form i i came away watching your
your talk with the same feeling i had
when i read your book how could one
person
know so much really a pleasure to to
spend some time with you
thank you so much i cannot tell you what
an immense honor it is to have you join
the conversation and i'm so grateful to
you
so we're we're supposed to do some
questioning um and
back and forth but i thought first i
would surprise you
i hadn't planned on this uh but when you
spoke about uh sheet lima
um i'm reminded that lemma really
had two different
meanings in the indian household
frequently when you would go to find
cases of smallpox
whether you were an indian or a
westerner you would not be permitted
in a house that had smallpox because
someone might say shitla is visiting us
and in that sense shitload was
protecting
and at the same time shitala was
synonymous in many
parts of india with the the bad parts of
smallpox
and of course there were shiita lima
temples all over and shidlama
images all over and earlier before we
began this you mentioned a friend of
both of ours
mahindra dutta and he gave me a gift
after we had eradicated smallpox and i'm
going to show it to you
and this is what's going to surprise you
oh that's beautiful i wish i had my
effigy my office in the center for
advanced study of behavioral sciences
had a whole alter dedicated to sitler
oh that's beautiful but i think that's a
testimony
in some ways to to what you managed to
do which is to kind of
i think exactly what i was saying to
xander which is
you know to kind of understand that
sitala as you said
was both a protector a visitation you
know the ma
the you know you were possessed by the
ma the ma was there with you
but also of course you know she was the
one who was associated with
with having you you're having contracted
smallpox
but to be able to understand that i mean
i've heard these stories legendary of
your
kind of going through marketplaces with
sitala icons you know you're camping at
sitalamanders
but you know i think that that degree of
cultural sensitivity but also just
understanding as i was saying to xander
what kind of
the ecosystem of the understandings of
of sickness and healing were
and to be able to present vaccines as
being within that
rather than this kind of rejection of it
to me was such a critical component
of the success again of the vaccine
vaccination campaign against smallpox
when you talk about meeting people where
they are
probably no place in the world has there
ever been a more
legitimate reason to have an anti-vaxx
movement than india because in order to
make the vaccine
you had to take cows and
imprison them and scarify their belly
and implant pops
and then harvest it and kill the cow so
in order to get the vaccine
the death of something sacred and
honored and loved in india a cow
so we we encounter a tremendous amount
of resistance i wouldn't call it
resistance i think it was the right
response it was so ferocious that
as you know the 1895 bengal immunity act
was created one of the very few laws
that was laid down because of the
calcutta aversion to being
vaccinated so when we were in the
program and towards the end of it
when we felt that this reaction against
the vaccine was understandable and
legitimate
my wife garage and i would stay in
sheikh lima temples we would sleep in
the temples
we would talk to the pujaris and we
would say
look how could what can we do this
disease is killing children and they
would say well that's not shitless
intention
and we would talk about what was the
intentionality of the deity
and in the end we reached an
understanding
and the understanding was the who said
listen we have seven
other rash diseases that shithu lama
is in charge of maybe we can help you
with this
one and when i told him that my guru had
said
that the eradication of smallpox was
god's gift
to humanity these uh pujaris
said let us help you and they would take
us to the villages
they would sign the posters they would
guide us to vaccinate people they would
show us where cases were
and we could not have eradicated uh
smallpox without the help
of sheet lamar and her priests
it couldn't absolutely i think it's you
know every time i hear it even though
i've you know been in the archives for
far too long i've you know read
everything you've written it's still
such a poignant moving story and of
course it's resonant
if we go back to you know if we again go
back to this theme of learning from
other pandemics
i keep going back to ebola and the fact
that so much of the transmission was
happening through funeral rituals
and much you know the kind of advising
of people to just stop laying their
hands on the cops was not enough
until as you kind of point out the they
were able to get
the buy-in the support the endorsement
of the religious leaders the clergy who
said you know we can kind of send the
spirits on
without the healing touch can happen you
know from afar
but i think that kind of careful
cultural work
requires you know it requires
institutions it requires empathy
and you know we were talking before we
went live that the cdc
which is such a hollowed-out institution
i mean you were part of the cdc
you and the who epidemiologists were
going across the world
because in a way the the battle against
kovid
is just we're not even there in terms of
in india there is still
so much vaccine scarcity there's also a
fair degree of hesitancy and
the international community the us the
cdc were so critical they were at the
vanguard
of the eradication of this deadly
infectious disease
and you were all there doing this kind
of work and so i can't help but think
you know
this is the kind of work we need to be
doing in the rural hinterland
in the us to be able to understand you
know
what are people's belief systems who can
we reach out to convince them
what are the messages that we can frame
this within and then how can we take
this to other parts of the world
which are slowly going to begin to kind
of move from a stage of
vaccine scarcity to vaccine abundance
and reluctance the way that we have in
the u.s
so i ask you as a historian what major
transformative social movement occurred
without
the religious institutions without the
churches
and then i asked the very tough question
which is right now about kovid
where are the churches where are the
temples
where the synagogues the mosques where
is the religious community
helping to vaccinate the
the country one third of the country is
unvaccinated 125 million
americans right now are completely
vulnerable
and around the world that number is
probably close to 7
billion who are still vulnerable
we won't have enough vaccine certainly
not to waste
and the united states and the uk have
purchased three times the amount of
vaccine
that we could ever use even if we
vaccinated everybody three times
so what what will we do when india is
creeping up to three or four percent
vaccinated
how how will we engage all of the
most powerful feelings of nationalism
and
uh in my mind the religious and
spiritual community
they've been absent from this battle
absolutely and i
you know so i'm a comparative political
scientist who
takes a historical view to this and
unfortunately
that those historical lessons are are on
the one hand quite evident and on the
other hand
the kind of taking up of that lessons as
you point out
larry is is missing so i think you're
right the kind of role of the clergy
that has
the role of religious institutions
that's something that needs to happen of
course in
india that has become further
complicated by the fact that of course
the rise of hindu nationalism
means that religion has taken on a very
different meaning
than when it was when you and nirja
you know whose articles i've also read
um you know
i laugh every time i say it they're just
brilliant right is that
is is i think that you know so so i i
worry as you say we begin to get to that
point in other parts of the world like
in india
because that relationship um you know of
people like me who
are not necessarily on board with hindu
nationalism
how do how do those you know it's become
so religion
itself much like in the us has become so
politicized
it has become so polarized that it's not
so easy to kind of
be able to take on board those religious
leaders or religious ideas
in the way that it was back in the 1960s
and 70s and so
you know i hate to kind of to kind of
bring
you know to make this negative again a
little bit but again the content of
nationalism has changed and so to me
the kind of challenge is this recovery
this kind of moral recovery
of an idea of nationalism that stands
above ethnic divisions and religious
divisions that can motivate people as a
kind of patriotic duty
and to be able to find some idea of
religion as spirituality
rather than as these kind of religious
institutions and political ideologies
to be able to so you know to me like
vaccination is at
is at once both a spiritual duty and a
patriotic call
that's how smallpox was eradicated it
was a combination
of spirituality and you know religious
leaders and
norms and trust and nationalism
and good science indeed well of course
the good science is the backdrop of
all of this i want to thank uh you larry
for joining us it's just
always good to see you um before you
leave though i want to touch on one
subject that is it's still
you know obviously being debated very
much right now and um
i think maybe the best way to put it you
know i know we're mostly talking about
vaccines um and how those work but also
i do want to touch on
on disease origin and and while this is
you know currently
you know gone back and forth in a debate
and does it matter
where how does these have origins
whether in synthetic
you know labs or in um you know places
where they jump
um naturally is this an area that we
need to care a lot about or should we be
mostly caring about
this other side of it of how we treat
things all right
i'll have you jump in on this before we
before you sign off with you
i i think we should care a lot about it
um
and and there's two meanings of the word
uh
origin in this sense and i'm not talking
necessarily about bioterrorism versus
uh bio error or uh
naturally occurring but the last death
from various major in the world i talk
often that i saw the last case of
variable major
in nature in the world but the last
death was a lab accident
in birmingham england a woman janet
parker in her twenties
a photographer who did nothing except
had her office
a floor above a lab that wasn't well
protected in the ventilation system
wafted
um smallpox so so we we need to
understand we didn't know that about
smallpox that was not part of our
understanding of how smallpox spread um
right now we need to understand the
origin of kovid
not to blame anybody lab accidents are
accidents
and they happen but we need to
understand how do we
how do we take care of the samples that
will be left with us
the theory is it was a bsl2 lab not a
bsl4 lab
if you saw the movie contagion you saw a
bsl4 lab the
kind of care that you have to take
we need to understand whether there are
other bad
forms of covid in nature that will hit
us not just with variants
on this corona virus but other coronary
viruses
yes we need to understand the origin but
not for the purposes of nationalism
not for the purposes of scoring points
but for understanding where this comes
from
and how we can prevent the next leap
from animals to humans and i'll just
leave
by saying every year there are three to
five viruses
that jump from animals to humans with
pandemic potential
unless we get together bury the hatchet
so to speak
bury our nationalism work together
globally solve these problems
the viruses are not going to stop coming
the question is
will we be as one world and one species
ready for that indeed well we'll get
brunner's answer next but thank you so
much larry it's really great to see you
as always thank you for having me
wonderful to see you thank you so much
okay well unable to get your opinion on
this i think i mean i think it was
actually a bsl4
lab that um that anthrax came out of uh
purposefully obviously after 9 11. so
you know we
we're seeing both bioterror and bio
error coming out of these things
um it always seems to be that when it
comes to the part that we're in now that
it's
it's largely irrelevant we're talking
about eradicating it and doesn't
in many cases it really doesn't matter
how it starts but i think obviously
looking forward it does matter
yeah absolutely and again to kind of
bring in how geopolitics factors into
this i mean larry knows this all too
well is that you know twos of two
smallpox samples were also kept one in
the soviet union one in the us
you know under seven layers of security
apparently at the cdc
so you know i think the point to me the
kind of critical point is i'm a
political scientist
and i study germs and i study diseases
and i study them because in as much as
they are a kind of scientific public
health issue they are a kind of deeply
political issue and i think this
question also just kind of
gets at that but i also but i do think
that in some ways um you know larry is
right is that this is not the first it's
not the last
you know like pandemic potential
in this case realized a contagion
disease that we have seen
and i think to me you know again being
able to distill those lessons
and continue to implement those lessons
and learn new lessons
is essential if we are going to have a
kind of hope at being able to kind of
continuously improvise as these
as these disease as these kind of germs
morph
indeed yeah well and it's you know i
think this idea you know as he pointed
out the
this notion that none of these diseases
have ever been eradicated without
um integrating religion and religious
leaders into that and how
you know sadly polarized that is in this
in the covet case
at the moment um but i appreciate that
by pointing it out i think you're
getting to
you know how we might have a shot at
this um kevin kelly one of our founders
um
often uh joins us on these uh sent in a
question that i thought would be
interesting
um is that have you studied the
difference um
in um how how well these types of things
are accepted
um of types of medicine are accepted
that are injected versus
uh you know pills like oral pills is
there a is there a more or less accepted
way of
of of health care arriving to people
is the injectable things just you know
more too scary
yeah i mean i think this is what is so
interesting historically and thank you
for that question because i think it
allows me to emphasize
a point that is that when the vaccine
that first vaccine the general vaccine
against
smallpox arrived it was actually much
more of a
break in southern china than it was in
india for precisely this reason
there had not been a vaccine or you know
the kind of pre-knowledge of the
the pre-vaccine the inoculation the
variolation
was mostly done up the nose nasal
encephalation
um or it was you know in the way that
unfortunately tragically the first act
of bioterrorism here in north america
happened blankets you know
clothes of of kind of smallpox patients
and so this idea of making an incision
into the skin
and injecting again as larry said animal
matter
into your skin was a big
big difference a big potential just
juncture between the way
that smartbox had been controlled
previously which is by you know
snorting something up your nose or kind
of wearing someone else's clothes
combined with these herbal formulas and
certain
diets that accompanied this but i think
what's so critical and i think to me
the the answer to the short answer to
the question is i think
it can matter it need not matter the
critical thing is how it's framed and
presented
and so to me the kind of genius of these
chinese
vaccinators the the gentry the officials
was the way in which they linked
this new incision into the arm with what
they
previously knew about incisions which
was acupuncture
which was very different you know the
lancet looked very different from an
acupuncture needle an acupuncture needle
is
is really thinner than a human hair and
it was a very different
mode of treatment but to be able to kind
of make that similarity make that kind
of cognitive bridge
which allowed what daniel kahneman who
was also a fellow at
caspase to be able to say you know that
kind of cognitive
link that consonants that was created
and so
in some ways that kind of incision into
the arm the needle
could have been such a major stumbling
block but it wasn't
because of the fact that it was linked
to this kind of existing centuries-old
very trusted very effective form
of medicine and then you know to kind to
compare it to india
in some ways they were used to an
injection and incision
because that's how variation had been
happening for centuries before the
arrival of the vaccine
so people were very used to a vario
later
who was called a tikadar coming out and
making a little scratch on your arm and
it was often in the upper arm
so in a way the technology was very very
analogous and
far more analogous in india than in
china
and yet it was in india that the vaccine
was resisted because they could not make
that bridge
because of you know what we began by
discussing is that now
with this kind of civilizing colonial
benevolence
uh vaccines had to be presented as
something so new and so completely
different and
you know such a major improvement from
this backward superstitious practice of
violation
is that they completely missed that
opportunity to be able to link the
technology
and that was that was actually a major
problem is they would
you know most of the actual vaccinators
were indian because of course you know
britain colonized india with a few
hundred
scotsmen and irishmen um and so you know
when the
various laters were going and doing
their rounds and usually the british
the kind of monitoring official would
stand on a little hillock he
could not actually tell whether the
tikka dar was performing
a variolation or a vaccination because
the technology of
incision was so similar so i think that
you know to me
there's no necessary relationship
between a kind of particular technology
whether that is
a prick or up your nose you know i once
got the flu shot
up my nose which was quite new for me
even though it's actually a very ancient
technology so i i think it's more the
framing of the technology than the kind
of science or the technology or the
technique itself
interesting yeah and how that might have
played a role in culture up to that
point
uh yes yeah well um we're gonna wrap up
our questions but we do have another one
here from our youtube thread from uh
from john i think it's a very
interesting question that's also
linked to so many other kind of
questions of science and how they get
adopted by
by society um you know vaccination as
well as something like
climate change they both have you know
they have um
ways of acting on them that may help fix
them in the present and as you mentioned
we are presenting
but we are discounting that future but
they also have this problem
that you know inaction can create
very long-term bad consequences um and
this it's this odd
question of of how how we balance
inaction
um and kind of this wait and see
attitude to
taking action now and thinking that it's
you know it's going to
take have a have a difference in the
future i just wanted to see if you could
talk a little bit about
how we feel you know kind of how society
feels about inaction versus action in
these cases
yeah and i think this you know question
about the future and how that plays into
our decision making
is obviously close to your heart and
that of the long now foundation
and i think that the key thing again
that it returns
that i kind of return to is to
understand again the way in which
like the way that we think about the
future can change again depending on how
it is framed
and who it is that is presenting that
information to us and so
you know we all have visions of the
future it's what kind of motivates us in
many ways
you know the kind of procreation are
both our ancestors but also
our kind of descendants and so i think
that
almost every and every civilization has
had some idea
of you know being able to reach out to
the future
and kind of have this threat so i think
to me that
the key issue again is this question of
how is it that we kind of link a present
predicament to an understanding of the
future
who links it and is that considered a
legitimate
trustworthy linking and so i think
again we have there's a lot of research
on climate change a lot of political
scientists who've shown
that exactly the same scientific content
presented
by different institutions who enjoy
varying degrees of authority and their
framing
in different ways can lead to
drastically different
attitudes on the part of otherwise
similar people
towards that kind of threat of climate
change
and so i think you know again the future
is just not one thing
the future is how we imagine it and how
we think of it and how we find ourselves
at this present moment
linked to that idea of the future and i
think that's where the potential
of a kind of creative construction lies
and i think again you know kind of
understanding
the socio-political foundations of trust
legitimacy and authority
and of understanding how we process
information
is what allows us to make that link and
present a particular vision of the
future
that would allow people to be more alert
more cognizant
and more active about a very real and
present
threat uh to our descendants from
climate change
um but you know we can also see climate
change around us today so
you know to me it's you know as a kind
of constructivist so much of this is the
kind of
creative construction as it relates to
structures of authority
um in the kind of society that we live
in
thank you and um you know last question
um you know now that you're back at home
with your family um
is what's what's next for you what's
your what's your next project where are
you what are you researching now
so getting this book done and out is
very much the so my future
right now is is not it's not you know
the long now
is for me the the kind of getting this
book out
because in some ways i began working on
this book when you know
vaccination and infectious diseases are
very unsexy topics it's kind of like you
know before it was cool yeah
before it was cool so i've been working
on this for far too long
and in some ways i think you know it has
become tragically relevant today
but um but you know just the archives
can immerse you there's always so much
more but i do think i have something
quite important to say and so the
challenge for me is really
to be able to kind of get it written and
so it's a more immediate future and then
of course you know questions of public
health and nationalism
and kind of remain i think somewhere in
that kind of
more longer future nice well i'm glad
that you started as early as you did so
you would be ready to talk to us
at such a relevant moment and thank you
so much really really appreciate having
you
no thank you so much for having me it
was a pleasure
and um i'd love to thank dr larry
brilliant who joined us as well
as well as our production team um we
have some talks coming up in the future
some of our first live talks in
over 18 months um and even and some of
those are going to be covering
uh similar subjects um such as how
quarantines have worked
and i'd love to thank our venue here the
hang gallery next door for hosting us
for this q a and i look forward to
seeing you all at our next talk thank
you so much
you